[Applause]
i don't see
trump as someone who's mentally ill i i
don't see it
only has people around him that is
feeding him the knowledge that he wants
to hear even if the knowledge is wrong i
don't think that's an exclusive quality
to crazy people
i would also say about trump from from
everybody that i've met that has met
trump
what everybody said to me it was the
same exact thing
but then they go this they go curious
i go what do you mean they go he just
asks questions
what do you do and then explain to me
what you do
and why you're good at it oh and why is
this like that why is this like that
and it was an interesting and i think
important characteristic now
does he want to be around does he want
to have like sick offense around him is
that the knock on him sure
or does he want to have people that will
execute
what he thinks is the right thing to do
and
he feels like in dc if he doesn't have
someone who's on his side he has someone
who's actively trying
to take him down that would be what i'm
thinking like
if i'm going to dc right i'm bringing
y'all
not because i think y'all agree with me
because i think that y'all are going to
give me the best perspective
maybe at the end of the day we have like
the common goal together all right but
akash might be like nah you're going too
crazy you got to pull back on that
you know what i mean okay fine i agree
with you i'll pull back on that we all
want this to happen how we get to there
might have different methodology and
that's where you lean on people so maybe
he got people who agree
with where he wants the country to go
but they might disagree on the best way
to get there
does that make sense i get it but i
don't see it
it might be i might be completely wrong
and it could be wrong where he wants the
country to go you should not be able to
scratch your entire achilles tendon yo
so i put on some lotion so my i got
eaten up by bugs bro
i got literally destroyed by bugs you
don't see all these bug bites bro
on my [ __ ] ankle bro i think they
came in when you were the [ __ ]
honeycombs on your feet
literally you walked in look at all
these bug bites all over me because you
had two honeycombs
on your feet what you doing yo bro i'm
i'm going through a dog i might have
what do dogs have again please fleas bro
you got fleas
i might have fleas i really might have
it
all right what else we got what else we
got
okay uh what is the abortion thing with
kanye i know we touched on it but did we
really
pay you a million dollars you're not
getting abortion right and then he said
he almost aborted his daughter
yeah so he he he broke down crying
because he was like oh
that's why he's against abortion because
he's like if i would have had my way i
wouldn't have my daughter right now
and if his dad who didn't want him had
his way he wouldn't be alive
oh his dad didn't want him no really
that's what he
says but and not to mention there's a
movement
in within like black conservatism
specifically that's like harping on
abortion
as like a bit like one of their like uh
talking points yes
and in what way because they're like so
basically they put abortion clinics like
abortion leaders pop up in poor
neighborhoods
right and poor neighborhoods are
predominantly black in like urban cities
and stuff
right or uh maybe poor neighbors aren't
predominantly black
but they're gonna be a higher percentage
of black poor neighborhoods that's a
better way to put it right right right
and so as a result a lot of black people
in america have abortions
and they have them at higher rates than
like their representation of the
population or something yeah so i read
it was something like
50 of abortions something like that so
now black conservatives who are
obviously against abortion are like yo
they're killing our people blah blah
and so that's what right so that's
popped up in black conservative areas
and i think
he's got black conservatives in his ear
that are like yo you got to push us out
there
do you think that this could be like
controlled opposition he's not aware of
it but do you think that like
trump people that have not told him
that they're connected to trump but you
think trump people are like yo
go run this race you're gonna peel some
democratic voters off of biden you'll do
you'll be like ross perot remember ross
perot 100
he was big in texas right uh yeah he's
from dallas he's from
base in dallas he got clinton elected he
got [ __ ] clinton elected
because he ran at the same time
bush ran right i remember i was watching
an old ass snl from like 1991 or
something
but explain the scenario to people who
don't understand it was like so george
bush got elected george bush senior got
elected in 1988
his terms up in 92. i remember in 91
there was a saturday night live skit
sketch with all these democratic
candidates who wants to lose the
election to george bush because george
was so liked
he was a shoeing they're just like we're
not we loved reagan this guy is an
extension of reagan everything seems
okay
we're good with this clinton was like an
afterthought in that thing but then
clinton wins the democratic primary and
then
ross perot runs independently ross perot
is like a businessman
he's all about the economy based in
dallas he takes 20 percent of the
popular vote
and most of the people who are going to
vote for perot would have voted for
republican because it's financial i
don't i am fiscally conservative that's
what matters to me
when this bad ass business dude who was
the time one of the richer people in the
country is running
the economy's not doing great you're
like that's the guy i want to vote for
i'm a republican
he appeals to me so i'm going to vote
for him and that's what allowed clinton
to win
oh [ __ ] so maybe they're doing some
interference
maybe this is my very last uh podcast
when we talked about it you said that
right yeah
i think he's being placed there to take
away votes
from from biden but he i think it's
possible he doesn't
know that oh of course he doesn't like
they really charged him up on somebody
yeah you got this
you can really charge him up like he can
really win
like he has to know he has no chance of
winning and why are you even wasting
your time
the other theory is that he's just doing
it to promote music but he's not
mentioning any music he's not trying to
sell merch right now i
really honestly think in his head he
thinks he's running
to have a rally let me throw something
at y'all that is that might be a little
crazy let me throw something at y'all
let's say it's
how many months away from with the
election are we november is the election
three
so three months away let's say we're one
month out
trump goes yo
i'm tired of these [ __ ]
pedophiles and running [ __ ]
we're getting them all out of here we're
getting all these [ __ ] out of
here
i've been trying to find the best way to
do it over the last four years
i've been saying all this divisive
[ __ ] up [ __ ] because i i knew
that these group of people was gonna
love me no matter what and that's what i
needed to do to get in power
and get enough research and find out who
the [ __ ] they really were and how deeply
entrenched into the government they were
and what happens if he goes and listen
and i had enough with that i'm calling
him out i'm getting him the [ __ ] out
here
obviously he does it right around the
election time because it's supportive
but you cannot tell me there is a more
bipartisan uh
issue with complete or like bipartisan
support or whatever that term
is than just like don't [ __ ] kids right
like i don't care what side you're on
don't [ __ ] kids and if you do [ __ ] kids
you're a piece of [ __ ] and we should
just kill you right and what if he's
like yo i'm out in them
all the this prince andrew these
[ __ ] this
this is the island this is whatever
we've had all these investigations going
this entire time
we put in all these federal judges on
purpose so that they couldn't you know
get out scot-free if we did try to try
them
like what if he was like yo this is what
we've been doing the entire time a month
before the election
do you think that america switches and
goes all right go get them i think
people hey trump will not believe it at
all
you think there'll be a conspiracy yeah
and plus everybody keeps getting marked
out so you need like actual progress as
opposed to everybody that gets arrested
gets killed
and we don't find out anything i'm not
saying he does anything with
it i'm not saying he tries anybody he
just says it vocally
what y'all think happened that's his
sales pitch that's the sales i think
people would
i mean democrats for sure i don't know
about moderates would be like you hung
out with epstein all the time
what are you talking about you stopped
hanging out because of a [ __ ] land
deal
right not because of him landing his
dick in a 12 year old
that's the deal we were concerned about
okay marvel but
that's the q and on conspiracy right so
you hear people on there
explain that because i always hear q
anon but i don't really understand what
it is so
i'm to my understanding originated out
of 4chan which is like a uh
like a forum or a thread that's like
pretty unpoliced and unmoderated it's
just like
kind of like internet people like kind
of the drags of the internet not to
talk [ __ ] about 4chan but like right
they come in for you yeah i know
the ups like
it's just internet people that go to
like talk crazy without any type of
moderation and they started this
conspiracy
that trump is actually going to drain
the swamp and he's going to clean
everything up and he's getting all the
bad people out
so that's what drain the swamp comes
from i think he said
he said but but they heard it as coded
language we're like oh he's getting the
pedos out
we don't know okay obviously it looks a
little bit crazy
and i don't think that's gonna happen
but i do feel
that if go out go i think it all depends
on corona
all depends on the death toll the how
we're dealing with it
the election yeah if we have a vaccine
by october
yeah he might win because like right now
that's the main thing on everybody's
mind like you you wake up
and you go to sleep and at one point in
the day you thought about corona or
wearing a mask or something related to
corona so i think
until you are able to either get
something that's
bigger deal than corona nothing is going
to help him
nothing's going to matter besides the
death toll like it has to go down
let's say hypothetically speaking he
does come out with it
you're not a trump guy at all no
biden doesn't address it
biden goes ah that's conspiracy i don't
believe that [ __ ] trump is like he's in
on it he's one of them
who do you vote for oh if he's in on it
and if he's that's what trump does
brilliantly is he makes everybody else
toxic
right i need one i need to see some
proof first right crooked hillary lying
ted
boring jeb whatever he calls him sleepy
joe i mean creepy joe
so little marco it also depends on his
running mate
abide in front of me ah because it bites
in on it
[ __ ] get him the [ __ ] out of here but
if he has a good running mate that's not
in on it you can trust that i can i'll
go with that
i just think it's an interesting thing
and i wonder if that starts to come out
a little bit more closer to election
like if he gets desperate
yeah because i think he's the
[ __ ] that's gets desperate and
then he just starts throwing haymakers
like remember he was like bill raped
three women and he brought him to the
[ __ ] debate one puss is one
the one guy who like murdered his
secretary what happened remember that
[ __ ]
no what happened i forgot who it was a
brother guy but like seth rich that guy
he accused some congressman in miami
like his secretary died
oh joe uh scarborough yeah he was like
someone go as joe scarborough i killed
his
secretary or something oh yeah and he
was having like an affair apparently
like
the secretary that he was having an
affair with ended up dying and he just
like called that [ __ ] out like matt
blatant
just like on twitter everyone's like
what you're doing it's gonna be it's
gonna be interesting that's a wild boy
right there that's gonna be trump don't
care
and he knows how like the pedo [ __ ] has
become mainstream it's part of the
conversation everybody's talking about
it
i would not be surprised and he's spoken
about it before there's videos out there
he was like yo that prince willie or
prince what is his name prince andrew
forgot that name i don't even like when
they say that prince
prince did that [ __ ] he was like prince
has some problems on that island
like he says that in like 2015. you know
prince got a lot of problems on that
island
and then you're saying like you know the
clintons you know like we're not friends
i know them but they might have a lot of
problems with that epstein guy
i think that's where maybe the q anon
thing got started or
i mean yeah that's all wrapped up in the
lore
it's just an interesting thing that it's
possible just like corona
there could be another topic with enough
force to throw shade on all the other
things that are so divisive
yeah you know what i'm saying like if
trump comes through whatever he's like
i don't have a vaccine i don't got
nothing and then biden is like
i promise you we will have a vaccine by
two weeks that
we're gonna do it and then it comes out
we're all going oh i want that guy to
lead us he's the one that saved us from
corona
even i think republicans are gonna go
well [ __ ] oh yeah listen
i wanna be with the guy who got us the
vaccine yeah not i don't know how a
candidate would do that but given that
given this situation where there are two
things that are like that heavy yeah
i think it could happen yeah part of me
thinks that the q a conspiracies and
like believing that trump is fighting
for the for the good guys
is people that some of it is people
seeing trump do crazy [ __ ]
and going like i hope he's on our side
they see him doing such crazy stuff that
is like more comforting it's like the
thing we talked about in the piece it's
more governing to believe
that he's you know fighting for good and
that all of like the
shenanigans and all the antics is like
pulling for the
you know for us yeah it's like sometimes
we believe the conspiracy because it
puts us at ease more
yeah you know like like i think in the
piece the thing we said was
uh was the exact line it was like we
would rather believe that it's a bio
weapon from china
than something completely natural that
just might pop up and kill us again some
other time
that exposes like how fragile existence
is [ __ ] scary is that
one day and corona 20 is coming out or
kobe 20 or whatever
like that's terrifying to believe i'd
rather believe china did then we could
spank china
no more yep
you